and if we feel this way after three
weeks i can't imagine how we'll feel in
a couple of months
laurel and carrington you two rode a
roller coaster up until the very end how
are you guys feeling
i feel very accomplished i came to love
island to find a girl that
not only i want but i need in my life
someone who's gonna be great for me
and i talked around as i should i found
laurel
and it was a roller coaster but i
accomplished what i wanted so i'm very
happy about it we both did you know have
very different journeys i came in later
in the game but
i honestly didn't think i was going to
leave costume where i've said that
multiple times but carrington came
through and we actually
built something from the ground up it's
really great that we're going to carry
into the outside world which is exciting
because that's both what we came in here
looking for
i'm going to pick a bone with carrington
because carrington sometimes it seems
like your head was on a little bit of a
swivel
yeah and we love laurel so where are you
now are are we feeling monogamous
we're going to go forward what's what's
the next steps here
me and laurel have very realistic
expectations for the outside world
we do not want to just end like most
couples do
when they go on a show like this right
we're not boyfriend and girlfriend but
we are going to talk to each other we're
going to text we're going to call
the time it is going to be very weird
being apart but
that's what we need to really figure out
how much we want each other because
we've never missed each other we've been
with each other every hour of the day so
this is going to be very good for us i
already have my plans to go to alabama
to see her
we're going to be doing you know one or
two trips a month
until we decide okay let's send it
i went into the villa talking to
multiple people for a reason so when i
met laurel
i did feel like she was the girl for me
but lakey came in
and i still got to know her i felt as if
it was the right thing to do at the time
i do regret it but at the end of the day
she knows how i feel about her i am
working consistently to
show her how much i feel and i'm just
happy so
yeah we're definitely past that it was
you know one
small bump in the road it wasn't you
know anything crazy
it was hard to lift through i mean i was
pretty emotional i think everyone saw
that
and i'm just happy to be where we are
now and then we made in the final four
is insane
i don't want to bring up old wounds but
i do want to give carrington the the
chance to address something that laykin
said to me when we
had our exit interview she said that she
was concerned that
carrington you were just with laurel for
the show and that it will change your
tune as soon as the camera stop
rolling is there any truth to that
there's none and
the funny thing about lakin is she was
trying to be in little shoes she said
many times
laurel was not right for me and she
wanted to be with me so
this is just out of spite and me and
laurel know that
we wouldn't listen to someone who wants
to talk about a relationship who
clearly wanted to be with me i mean
it just wouldn't make any sense to
really listen to herself i don't really
have much to say on that
i was put in a competition it was just
you know
really an emotional rollercoaster for me
i don't want to relive it so
it's kind of in the past i think you
know we're mainly focused on ourselves
moving forward not really about
what anyone else has to say or anyone's
negative opinions because obviously you
know
with this show i'm sure there's going to
be some of those but we're trying to
like
focus on the positives for sure and if i
was really just caring about the show
or trying to be fake in any way i would
have stuck with the first
person you know kirsten was very into me
i ended up wanting to be friends with
her and you know i could have just faked
it but i didn't i was real to myself
i was reeled my heart and it took me to
a good place so
i feel like you know even the fact of
him wanting to get to know lake and
shows a lot about
you know how he viewed the experience
really taking it in and like making the
most of it
if he was only worried about the show
then i feel like
he could have easily just picked her as
me because at that point he had already
gotten to know her and that was already
kind of
an issue so sticking with me really
wouldn't have made a difference honestly
i do want to point out there's a moment
that i really like respected you
carrington and that's when you faced
laurel's parents and
you were like yeah i'm going to talk
about this laurel how important was that
moment to you
that moment i literally breathe live so
much my family means so much to me and i
think
that like i'm super family oriented i
talk to my mom and dad
every single day my dad is literally my
best friend which is so funny because he
you know
he's an older man so if the relationship
we have is amazing and i knew
going into that conversation that my
parents were going to have you know
things to say
carrots and or questions to ask that
we're going to be hard hitting i was so
proud sitting in that moment watching
him talk to them the way he handled
himself was amazing i
was well shocked with the fact you know
that
he was being how he was he was like so
respectful and just like taking
everything he really didn't have
anything to say back he wasn't making
any excuses he just told them
exactly you know what happened and you
know his plans moving forward with me
and
i think my parents were elated by the
fact that he was
so well respectful and i think they
loved him honestly
i know that there wasn't going to be any
issues about
them being hateful or anything like that
definitely
i think that they like him a lot so i'm
not worried about it and
for the fact for them to give me that
validation our relationship just meant
the world to me so
i want to talk about another really
special connection and that was the
relationship between
laurel and kirsten which was super
special
you know i talked to kirsten after and
she made it clear to me that she did
still
have feelings for carrington even up
until leaving and after leaving the
villa but
she wanted to support you guys step
aside i i'm just curious because we just
don't see friendships like this very
often like how
did your friendship how do you feel like
it worked so well
yeah honestly it was so weird to me as
well i feel like you know
our friendship was not conventional at
all i feel like it was
probably even weird for carrington a
little bit but i feel like because she
had been through some of the same
situations
and in the same boat as you know i was
going through
that carrington like put her in we just
kind of bonded over that we wanted over
a lot of things actually she's a great
girl i love her to death i can't wait to
get out of here and like hang out with
her and talk with her
i miss her yeah the friendship that we
have is not conventional at all but it
it works like i feel like we are two
totally different people kind of like
carrington and i and we do bring out the
best in each other like she brings a
fiery fun side to me and then i
you know bring her down to earth and
humble her a little bit
so it worked really well she is an
amazing girl
and you know at first i was super
intimidated by coming
in and like seeing her standing alone i
was really nervous especially
with the entrance that carrington and i
made um i didn't want her to hate me
and she was like i could never hate you
like after the fact once she got to know
me she said she thought i was gonna be
a [ __ ] at first i guess because the way
i looked and we just worked past all of
that
and it took a few days but then we
really warmed up to each other and
she was i would say my best friend in
the villa honestly
speaking of that entrance uh yeah yeah
what
what what was that karen everybody
in their hearts and minds knew kirsten
was going to have a guy
i knew it everybody did there was
sometimes the guys made jokes like what
if she is single but we'd all like no
she's gonna pick somebody she is so
special she's
she's great tons of guys want to get to
know her right so i knew she would have
a guy
so i thought so i was thinking i'll come
down
single and just scare this guy a little
bit as a joke
and i have a girl and it's all fun and
games and then we get to know them and
be friends because
my whole thing with kirsten is although
we weren't going to be romantic i still
wanted to be your friend
100 and when i came down and did that i
was like oh i bet i gave this guy like a
shaking in the boots and then we'll
it'll be funny whatever
and she was single and so i was like oh
my god like i had no idea
i had no idea because she was just
boosting about i can't wait till guys
come in i'm like good for you like i
hope
you do find a guy i felt terrible about
it
it was not meant to be yeah
malicious at all if she was single i
would never have done that because
why would i purposely want to be
perceived and how i hurt her
so i'm so glad she believed me on that
forgave me
and you know when benny came in or
whoever came and always told her
i always told them please don't kiss me
she's amazing
she needs somebody and i would just
speak highly of her
she just didn't find the connection
unfortunately so i wish her the best and
i think she will
i don't know if she'll find something on
the outside there's no doubt in my mind
she's too great not to
going on what carrington was saying it
was not the best way to make an
entrance honestly it was not good but we
did all think that she was gonna have a
guy there and
she did make that statement for you and
the fact that you know you still
want to get to know me meant a lot like
i mean if a girl
was standing for me by herself and i was
a guy i would take that as
a huge gesture and in the moment i wish
i did take it more as a gesture i was
just so
shocked and embarrassed i didn't really
have anything to say i was just like uh
i have no idea this is gonna happen so
yeah
but i respect her for doing that like
she made her you know final move and
that was that but i know that she still
has feelings for farrington and
um i think that where she comes from is
a place of wanting what's best for him
and realizing that we do
work so well together and that's how we
were all able to get past the whole
situation
how do you hope that you were perceived
by viewers at the end of the day
i hope that people saw me as
honest because i went in there to
experience
a reality game show i wanted to talk to
people
everybody that came in male or female
was amazing
with a great personality very good
looking like
my goal wasn't to come in find someone
early and fall in love in four weeks my
goal was to
find someone to bring to the outside
world if i fell in love
during the show awesome but i wasn't
just there to try to fall in love with
someone who
didn't make me have those feelings it
was just to find somebody me and laurel
have a late start but
there's plenty of time to find love so i
hope they just saw that
i had a normal dating experience and it
was just film
you talk to people and you realize
there's one person you want to talk to
in particular that's how it goes
on the outside that's how i treated the
show so just really
yeah i just hope that i came off as
myself so
that's pretty much it i feel like you
know through all of that
you you don't really get caught up in
the cameras and stuff like that but
sometimes
being in these situations you don't want
to lose yourself
and so i really hope that you know i
stayed true to myself and
i came off as genuine authentic that's
what i hope for most